Okay,
running.
All right,
so,
so let's talk about your brain.
So there's lots of different ways of
dividing up the brain and believe me,
people are still arguing about how to do
that.
So,
um,
I don't remember if I
signed the Swanson paper to you as a
reading.
Do you,
do any of you remember that?
Yes,
it's there.
It's very hard paper.
Very,
very,
very hard.
What I want you to do is to familiarize
yourself with it.
I mean it,
someone's whole life work and he's
really smart so you're just not going to
be able to digest the entire paper,
but it's a brilliant paper and Swanson
is a developmental neuro added an
anatomist and he basically envisions the
brain using a conceptual schema that's
based on how it transforms itself.
I think I turned it on across time.
So,
and what I really love about Swanson is
that he builds the brain from the bottom
up,
from the body upwards.
Okay?
So,
and that's incredibly useful because
there's a real dualism that still
saturates almost all of the conceptions
that you hear about the brain in most
areas in psychology,
certainly being one of those,
we kind of treat the brain as if it's
the place of the mind and the mind to
something separate from the body,
and you could just sort of take your
brain out of your body and you'd still
have a mind and it's like no wrong.
One of the things the ai people
discovered after many decades of trying
to make things intelligent was that
until they put them in a body,
things weren't intelligent.
So intelligent seems integrally linked
to the ability to maneuver yourself
through space in a physically embodied,
limited forum and to manipulate the
world.
So,
so your body is.
Your brain is first of all,
your brain isn't in your head anyways.
It's distributed throughout your body.
All you have to do is look at the
nervous system to figure that out.
Second,
there's more neurons in your autonomic
nervous system than there are in your
central nervous system.
I mean,
you know,
your brain is not only in your head,
it's a really foolish way of thinking
about it,
so all right.
Having said that,
there are multiple ways of
conceptualizing the brain and a lot of
whether or not the conceptual structure
is accurate is whether or not it's
useful,
so I'm going to go through a couple
because they are useful in different
ways.
This is one that's basically based on
the model that Russian neuropsychologist
produced,
led by Luria,
who was the greatest Russian
neuropsychologist and who had amazing
students and many of them laid down the
groundwork for the models that we're
going to describe and they were heavily
influenced by cybernetic thinking by the
way.
So the,
the two fields played like this over
from the 19 twenties till now.
Really so.
So from the,
from the Lurie and perspective,
your brain is basically something that
acts.
It's acts in the world and perceives the
world,
and the back half of the brain,
roughly speaking,
is for perceiving and the front half is
for acting.
Now here's something to think about.
You know,
I'm sure you've been taught the
prefrontal cortex is the seat of
abstract thought.
You know the seat of executive decision
making,
for example.
It's like I'm not so convinced about
that theory for a variety of reasons,
but one of the things that's that is
true about the prefrontal cortex is that
during the course of evolution,
it grew out of the motor cortex,
so if you look at this representation,
the top one there is the primary zone,
which is the motor strip,
and then the secondary zone,
which is the premotor strip and the
tertiary zone,
which is the prefrontal Cortex,
and basically what happened was that
first animals learn how to act and then
they learned how to represent actions
before they implemented them.
So the purpose of thinking is to
represent actions before you implement
them,
but it's not only auctions because there
aren't only actions,
right?
Because to act,
you also have to perceive and so really
what the prefrontal cortex does is run
simulations of how a personality might
operate and embodied personality might
operate in a fictional world and that's
what you're doing when you're thinking
it's also what you're doing when you're
watching movies or reading fiction or
any of those sorts of things,
right?
Instead of having to act something out
and potentially dying as a consequence
of it,
you can watch something being simulated
and see what happens and then if the
outcome is good,
you can implement it and if the outcome
isn't good,
then you can let it die.
And so I think it was Alfred North
Whitehead that said,
um,
the purpose of thought is so that we can
let our hypotheses die instead of us.
That's smart.
That's a very smart thing.
And so what,
what's happened in some senses that
human beings have gone from evolution to
mete evolution,
right?
Instead of evolving,
we can model evolution and then
implement.
The idea is the personality,
so to speak,
that we think are most functional.
And we let the,
we let our fantasy do the selection
instead of the actual world and it's a
brilliant solution,
so brilliant solution.
So in some sense the sensory unit,
which is the back half of the brain is
setting up your frameworks of perception
and integrating them.
And then the front half is determining
how to sequence activities and modes of
perception in order to act successfully
in the world.
Right?
And so there's the actual implementation
of the auction and then there's the
modeling of the implementation,
which is what gives rise to thinking.
And I,
I do think that it's very useful to
think of thinking as a simulated
personality.
Fundamentally you're running avatars of
yourself in some sense in your
imagination and trying to determine ones
are going to be successful.
Now you may have noticed,
given that I used the word Avatar,
that we've also now figured out who
acts,
how to externalize the process of
fantasy back into the actual world so
that we can run simulations in fantasy
on machinery and we can play out
potentials that way instead of only
having to do it in our brain.
You know?
And it's,
that's very,
very smart,
that's,
that's extraordinarily smart and it's
really going to change things.
God only knows for how.
So one of the things about Larry is
model.
You see that there's primary,
secondary,
and tertiary zones.
The tertiary zones are zones of
integration,
the primary zones or zones where,
especially in the sensory systems where
each senses elaborated in its entirety,
resolution sense before it becomes
integrated with the other senses.
And so the tertiary zones are actually
areas of overlap between the sense
between the census.
So for example,
when you,
when you read silently my experience of
reading silently as I hear the words in
my head,
so to speak,
while you might think,
well,
you know,
you look at a word and you hear it in
your head,
how,
how in the world is that possible?
And the answer is your eyes are using
your auditory system.
So there's overlap between the visual
and the auditory system in the tertiary
zones.
And so basically what you're doing is
hearing with your eyes and you know,
your consciousness has this property of
unification,
right?
It's sort of like a unified experience.
And Larry,
I believe that it was the tertiary zones
that gave rise to that phenomena of
unified experience.
He's a very smart character.
So the point is,
is that the motor unit is basically
utilize the part of us that does
planning forward planning and forward
thinking is utilized to layout simulated
personalities in the world.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
So,
okay,
so that's one kind of neurological
model.
Now,
let's see.
You want to go to more of the neurology
here first.
All right,
so if you look at the motor strip,
this is called a whole mount keyless.
And when wilder penfield was initially
doing open like brain surgery on people
with epilepsy,
you know,
you're generally conscious during brain
surgery,
which is rather horrifying thing to
contemplate because they don't want to
cut out a part that you might need.
And so they poke around in there often
with electrodes and you know,
you can report what's happening to you.
Um,
well,
what pennfield did was,
was do Electra Electra electrode mapping
of the manner in which your body was
represented in the primary motor area
that was responsible for,
for sequencing action.
And what he found was this,
now usually you don't see it like that
because the way your body is laid out in
your brain,
it's sort of torn apart and stretched
out over the strip.
And there's weird,
there's weird places where the parts
come together.
So for example,
there's a motor court,
a motor Homunculus,
and there's a sensory homonculus.
And one of the weird characteristics of
the sensory homonculus is that the
genital region is right beside the
region for the feet.
And one of the things that you can infer
from that is that's why people take such
delight in such things as foot massages
and why feet fetishes,
for example,
are quite common because the areas do
bleed into one another.
So that's pretty amusing.
So anyways,
there's the hmong canvas,
have you might say,
well,
that's how your brain thinks of your
body in terms of what you can do with
your body.
And so that's like a human being.
That's in fact,
that might be more what a human being is
like.
Then the human being used,
see when you just look at a human being
and what you see is,
well,
we're pretty handy when we're pretty
damn mouthy.
And so one of the ways you can think
about that,
and I think it's right,
is that human beings running around
taking things apart and putting them
back together with their hands and then
they talk about that all the time.
And,
and we have a tremendous amount of
control over our tongue.
Now it's wired up right at birth by the
way,
and lips as well.
So that's a primary investigative
Oregon,
you know,
and it's used for multiple purposes.
So,
you know,
children really explore the world with
their lips and tongue.
And of course it's a primary area for
sexual exploration,
but it's also,
uh,
it's also the part of our body that we
use to transform the things that we can
do with our hands into patterns of
communication so that we can speak about
what we do with our hands so that other
people can learn how to do that with
their hands.
And if you look at your hands,
what you'll see is you're mostly thumbs
right in,
you know,
one of the things that you always learn
from scientists is that it's an
opposable thumb that makes us human.
And certainly the thumb,
especially on the right hand is like you
see you've got more motor cortex devoted
to your damn thumb than you do to your
whole body.
And that's because,
well,
I tried picking up a ranch with your
back.
You know,
you're just not going to get very far.
And so it's really useful to think about
the brain body in this hunkeler killer
fashion because it also helps you
understand other things because you'll
hear people say,
well,
dolphins are super human in their
intelligence because they're in
centralization.
Quotient is higher than ours,
and the encephalization quotient is the
ratio of brain tissue to the race to
bodyweight.
Fundamentally brain weight to body
weight.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a measure of intelligence.
But the thing is is that imagine adults
in homonculus.
It's like what the hell are they going
to do with all that intelligence?
Like nose up some dirt on the bottom of
the ocean.
That's about it.
They can't build anything.
They can't take things apart and put
them back together.
And so whatever their brain is being
used for,
it has very little relationship to what
our brain is being used for.
Our bodies are articulated where Adolfo
does sort of like a test tube,
you know,
and they can swim like mad and they're
obviously extremely playful,
which is one of the attributes of
intelligent creatures,
but they're not taking things apart and
putting them back together like we are.
And that's what we're doing all the
time.
We do that with our speech is in fact
the,
the essence of taking things apart and
putting them back together.
You know,
and the hypothesis are with,
with regards to speech development that
we.
We developed our capacity for
articulated movement before we developed
our capacity for language and that the
only reason we ever developed a capacity
for language was because it sort of
developed as a secondary consequence of
our developed ability to produce
articulated action.
Now the two things probably spiraled
across time,
so I don't think you can.
You know,
it's not a chicken came first and then
the egg issue,
it's that chickens have eggs and eggs
have chickens and that just keeps going.
But the point is is that our ability to
represent things in an articulate manner
is directly related to our ability to
use our joints in an articulated manner.
And so that's what we're like in the
world.
We're out there doing things to it and
then talking about it,
we're very handy and we're very mouthy.
So that's useful to know because that's
sort of how the brain pictures of the
body and the fact that the brain
pictures of the body that way means that
that's how the brain conceptualizes the
body as an entity for use in,
in,
in the environment.
And so you say,
well,
how do human beings adapt?
Well,
we run around taking things apart and
putting them back together with her
hands and talking about it and we're
very good at that.
And so you could say,
well,
in some sense that's our primary.
I think that that's.
It's a reflect.
No,
it's a reflection of the same processes
that gave rise to the idea of the hero
because there's two ways of adapting to
the world in some sense.
One way is just to do what everyone else
has done.
That's always worked.
All animals do that.
That's what they do.
Like bears now and bears a thousand
years ago.
It's like they're the same bear even
though they're very complicated.
Same with chimps.
You know,
people say chimps have culture and can
make tools.
It's like,
that's wrong,
and here's why it's wrong.
If a chimp could increase its domain of
cultural expertise by a 10th of a
percent,
a generation,
which is like nothing,
well run that for 7 million years at
compound interest and what happens?
Well,
you get drawn to,
right?
I mean I don't know how much we
transform our culture with each
generation,
but doesn't have to be very damn much
for there to be cities after 2 million
years of iteration.
Well,
chimps are still living in the jungle
now.
They do use tools,
but what seems to happen is that the
environment,
and they do use different tools in
different locales,
but what seems to happen is that the
environment suggests the tools to them
so they have a certain level of
intelligence and they can figure out how
to use what's at hand and what's at hand
is different in different places.
So they use different tools,
but that doesn't mean they're thinking
up different tools.
They're not clearly because there's no
accumulation.
There's no accumulation of culture.
So I don't see how you can escape from
that mathematical argument and you can
make the same argument to pretty much
any other creature.
Even ants,
it's like they're making the same damn
ant hills they were making or God only
knows how long ago.
I mean they're very successful at it,
but there's,
there's no innovation and so being the
same as the things that live before you
that lived is a pretty good strategy,
but that isn't the human strategy or
it's actually half the human strategy
because half our strategy is to do what
everyone else has always done and the
other half is to fix that where it's not
working very well or at least to try to
fix it.
And I think this is an excellent
representation of the abilities we have
embodied to do precisely that.
So here's another way of thinking about
the brain.
This is mostly partly from Laurie again
and the Russians.
This is from one of his students whose
name is [inaudible],
Conan Goldberg,
who's a practicing neuroscientist to New
York.
And I think he's a very bright guy.
And I like his theory because you know,
you've heard classic theories about
linguistic versus non linguistic
hemisphere.
So the the left hemisphere usually is
regarded as the linguistic hemisphere
because in right-handed males in
particular,
language tends to be pretty located in
the left hemisphere.
Now,
what I would say instead of that is that
there are linguistic and non linguistic
systems in the brain and most of the
time they segregate out so that the
linguistic system is in the left
hemisphere and the non linguistic system
is in the right hemisphere,
but it doesn't have to happen that way.
It can be reversed with people who are
left handed.
It's more distributed in women,
and if you lose your whole right
hemisphere when you're like 18 months
old so you don't even have a right
hemisphere,
your left hemisphere will specialize so
that it has the linguistic system and
unknown linguistic system.
Partly the way to think about that is
that you know you're the top part of
your brain,
the cortical cap.
You can kind of think about that as a
plenary valence territory.
Lots of things could happen to it,
and what happens is that as you develop
the underlying systems,
the more biologically archaic systems
colonize the Cortex.
They fight.
They fight basically,
so you know,
your ears in your eyes fight over which
part of the back of the brain they're
going to have access to and usually the
eyes when at the back part of the brain
in the years when more here.
But you know,
if you don't have any eyes,
the ears are going to call an ice the
visual systems.
And that's partly why.
If you can't see,
you can hear better.
So,
and even if you lose your hand,
like if you lose your thumb when you're
an adult,
what'll happen is the part,
the motor cortex that represents your
fingers will grow.
It'll grow into that area so that these
get you have more brain now devoted
towards these fingers.
And if you're born without hands and use
your feet,
than the feet will start to develop a
map that looks like the map of the hand.
And there's some,
there's some flexibility in that even in
adulthood.
So there's,
there are these underlying systems that
grow up and you know,
they,
uh,
expand their capacity for
differentiation and synthesis by
occupying the cortex.
And that can happen in a variety of
ways,
even though it tends to happen in the
standard way during normal development.
So you could say it's better for your
eyes to invade the visual cortex because
it's sort of set up for that.
But if they can't advance,
the visual cortex ended invades the
auditory cortex that works like 90
percent as well.
It's something like that.
So the,
the top cortical cap is somewhat
specialized,
but it's not.
It's not.
It's not specialized to the degree that
it's lost its plasticity for the first
stages of development,
it's white child nurse.
Certain neuro psychology tends to be
such a mess is because the child's brain
is so plastic that you can't really say
with any certainty what any given part
of it happens to be doing except down in
the,
you know,
in the ancient areas where were some
stability has been attained.
So here's a way of conceptualizing the
difference between the left and the
right hemisphere.
Although again,
I wouldn't think about it that way.
Now the classic distinction is
linguistic non-linguistic.
Now Goldberg puts that on his head.
He says,
no,
linguistic non-linguistic is an emergent
property of a more fundamental division.
The more fundamental dee dee division is
between novelty and routine and anomaly
and that maps onto the sorts of
discussions that we've been having.
What do you have to deal with in the
world?
Things that work the way you think they
will and the way that you want them to,
and then things that don't,
so you have a system that works with the
things that work the way you want them
to,
and you have another system that deals
with the things that don't and roughly
speaking in the standard human brain.
The right hemisphere seems to be wired
for normal novelty detection,
emotional response,
and provisional processing.
Whereas the left hemisphere seems to be
specialized for routinized activities
and that would include representation in
language.
Now what happens,
for example,
if you practice a novel task,
is that when you first do it,
it's very computationally demanding and
so you set out a lot of energy and a lot
of your brain is at work,
especially in the right hemisphere and
as you practice it,
the right hemisphere stops working and
the left hemisphere works more and more,
and then a big part of the left
hemisphere works and then as you keep
practicing it,
that moves back until there's little
tiny part of your brain that's really
active when you're doing it and you're
good at it,
and so partly what happens is imagine it
this way,
is your brain.
When you're first trying to do something
complex,
it's maybe you're trying a new piano
piece or maybe you're doing some
improvisation.
It's like you're trying out all sorts of
things,
right?
A lot of it's error and error
correction.
It's a bloody mess.
It's exhausting.
You're doing all this and you're getting
rid of that thing that doesn't work in
that thing and you really practice this
part that's awkward,
and as you do that,
there are fewer and fewer errors.
Less variability and more and more
routinized,
and as you're doing that,
you're building a little machine at the
back of your head that does this
perfectly,
but that Rita can't do anything else.
Now,
that's really an interesting thing to
think about because what it implies is
whatever you practice,
you build into your implicit processing
systems,
so be careful what you practice because
once you get one of those little
machines back there and it really knows
what to do,
it's there.
Now you could build another little
machine that stops it from doing what
it's doing,
but it's pretty damn hard to get rid of
that machine once you've built it.
And so if you build it cocaine consuming
and desiring machine in your head,
that machine might end up being more
powerful than you are,
in which case you're basically ruined.
And that's really what happens to people
who are addicted because they build
expertise in cocaine seeking and
preparation and ingestion,
and it's really a powerful system
because it gets hit by dopamine every
time it's successful,
so it grows into this like monstrous
subpersonality and all that.
You need to activate that
subpersonality,
even if it's been dormant for a long
period of time and you know you're out
of the addiction is the site of
something associated with cocaine.
It's like up at comes and you're under
the.
That's the monkey on your back,
so to speak.
And so what happens when you're trying
to get people on addicted is that you
can take them to a treatment center and
let them go through all the minor league
horrors of withdrawal,
which are nowhere near as bad as people
generally claim.
So like heroin withdrawal is like a very
bad flu for about four days.
It's not exactly pleasant,
but it's not like alcohol withdrawal,
which just kills you often.
So you let the person get through all
that.
They're no longer dependent on the
chemical and they're fine as long as
they're in the treatment center,
but as soon as you put them back in
their environment and they see like
their friend Joe who's like,
you know,
they're drinking and cocaine partners
like poof.
Up comes the monster and they're gone.
And it's very,
very difficult to treat addictions.
And that's because an addiction is not a
psychological thing,
it's like you built a real monster in
your head and the pro and you're going
to have to like bore him to death over
years before it goes away.
And so,
and then if you're stressed,
well that's going to make it even more
difficult for you to inhibit it.
And well,
it's a bloody mess.
It's a mess.
Or if you get money,
which is like the worst thing that can
happen to you if your dad dicked,
you know,
it's like
I've had addicts as clients and the
worst thing that ever happens to the MS
dot payday,
it's like they're going on payday for
like three days.
They're gone and then they come back and
they're all beat to death because they,
you know,
they've screwed up horribly and they're
broke.
And so then they're safe till the next
time they get some money.
So.
So these are the sorts of associations
that go along with the novelty versus
root and ization model of the brain.
So.
So it is,
right,
right versus left roughly.
But it's better to think of it the other
way.
Novelty versus routinized,
and so the novelty processing part of
the brain is responsible for the
production of negative emotion.
Why?
Well,
when you run into something that you
don't expect,
you should immediately be cautious
because it's something that you don't
want might happen to you.
Now you can be excited because maybe
something new will happen,
but the but the prudent thing to do is
to be on alert first because God only
knows where you are.
So negative effect is part of it.
The thing you don't understand is a
threat.
That's the initial presumption and it's
prudent.
And then the other thing the right
hemisphere does is it stops your ongoing
behavior.
It does.
I would think about it as doing low
resolution hypothesis generation.
So for example,
if you're alone at night,
say,
and uh,
I don't know,
maybe you've watched a horror movie,
so you've got yourself nice and primed
and it's like one in the morning and
you're tired and you haven't eaten
anything for awhile and you hear some
weird noise in a room upstairs.
Images are going to flash through your
head and they're basically hypotheses
about what might be up there and you
know,
they can take bizarre form like
especially if you've been watching a
horror movie,
you know,
God only knows what you said,
some serial killer with like a hockey
mask up there or something you know,
but what your right hemisphere do is
doing is a very rapid,
quick and dirty processing of what the
horrible thing might be and that,
that you're on alert and you need to
kind of know what might be there and so
you over you know,
you overestimate might be the worst
thing you can imagine.
And that freeze you like a rat.
And if nothing else happens,
then well maybe it'll hide under the bed
which you know might be a useful
solution.
Or probably you'll like walk upstairs
and see what happens as you walk.
And if nothing comes leaping out and
killing you,
then you'll think,
well,
it's at least not the sort of monster
that leaps out and kills you when you
were walking up the stairs in the dark.
And so you're narrowing it.
You're developing a higher and higher
resolution model of the thing.
Then you know,
you go upstairs and you'll find that,
I don't know,
maybe your cat knocked a stuffed animal
onto the floor or something,
you know,
it narrows it down to irrelevancy,
but your right hemisphere is going to be
doing the initial quick and dirty
processing and those are,
those are low resolution
representations.
They're often archetipal,
you know,
it's like
things that go bump in the night.
What's a big category?
And you might think,
well,
is that a category?
It's like it's a reasonable category.
Things in the night that might hurt you.
That's the category of monsters
fundamentally.
So,
and you know what you might say,
well,
there's no such thing as monsters while
we already went through that with the
little book,
didn't we?
So of course there are.
It's just a low resolution category,
you know,
so.
But that doesn't mean it isn't useful.
Larger Motor actions are associated with
the part of the brain that does novelty
processing.
And again,
that's kind of low resolution,
right?
Because when you really figure something
out,
you can fiddle around with it in detail,
but if you're reacting in a quick and
dirty manner,
you're using your whole body so and on
the on the route and ization side of the
equation.
You've got positive emotion moving
forward because it's much more
appropriate to move forward and fully
articulated territory because you know
what you're doing and so if you
understand the territory and you've
articulated it,
then the probability that you're going
to get what you want when you're there,
it's going to be very high word
processing,
linear thinking,
detailed recognition,
detail generation,
fine motor action.
The actual physiological structure of
the left hemisphere is more
differentiated than the physiological
structure of the right hemisphere as
well,
and I want another way to think about it
I think is that the novelty processing
unit,
which is non linguistic,
is actually under the control of the
underlying limit.
LIMBIC and hypothalamic systems.
So it's bottom up.
It's sort of the part of your brain that
still acts like an animal act.
Whereas the linguistic part,
that's sort of the you that you think of
yourself as.
That's where the,
roughly speaking that the ego that's
talking to itself resides and I think it
is capable of top down control to a
larger degree than a novelty processing
unit,
which is still working as a quick and
dirty defense system and is highly
motivated by more primordial systems.
So how.
Okay,
so that's another way of thinking about
it.
Um,
we can zero in a little bit more.
There's been a lot of work on a brain
area called the hippocampus and the
hippocampus is the part of the brain
that moves information from short term
attention to longterm storage.
It seems to do that across time.
So for example,
if you suffer a maybe impact induced
amnesia,
a little bit of oxygen deprivation,
the hippocampus was a very active part
of the brain.
And so it doesn't like being deprived of
oxygen.
And so if you have brain trauma and you
get oxygen deprived,
it'll damage the hippocampus.
And then what often happens is you can't
remember the accident.
You can't remember what happened for six
months before the accident.
Your memory over the last 18 months is
pretty hazy,
but the farther back you go in time,
the more likely you are to have access
to the memories.
So what seems to happen is the
hippocampus seems to.
It does a bunch of things.
It moves.
It's.
It probably organizes your
autobiographical information initially
and then as it's elaborated in memory,
it moves up into critical
representations and becomes more
permanent and maybe articulation has
something to do with that.
Like I have a suspicion that partly what
you're doing when you're doing the
writing that you already did is you're
moving information more and more
permanently into cortical
representation,
cortical semantic representation.
You're detaching it from its underlying
emotional substrate,
so the hippocampus seems to be
responsible for that.
So if you take people whose hippocampus
because there's two of them have been
destroyed.
There are a few clinical case reports of
people like that.
They can't develop any new
autobiographical memory.
So the famous most famous of those
patients was a guy named h,
m who had bilateral hippocampus damage
partly from surgery and partly from
epilepsy,
and he was stuck in 1957 for 40 years.
He couldn't even really recognize
himself in a mirror because it was like
the old him and although he could learn
new procedures quite well as well as a
normal person,
he so he could learn a new procedure by
practicing it day after day.
But if you showed them the thing he
learned,
he'd say,
I never saw that before,
even though he got much better at it.
And so he was one of the first cases
that showed that memory systems were
dissociable.
So anyways,
the hippocampus is a big deal now.
The Russian neuropsychologist,
solar carve and vinegar Dov [inaudible],
followed by Jeffrey Gray,
followed up on this cybernetic model via
Luria and they came up with the
hypothesis that what the hippocampus was
doing was comparing what you expected to
happen in the world with what was
happening.
Okay.
So it's an expectation based model.
The idea was because they were
behaviorists,
the idea was there are stimuli in the
world,
they're actually there,
you're monitoring them,
you have a sense of what's going to
happen,
which is a cognitive expectation,
and as long as the two things are
occurring,
then your emotions,
particularly your threat response is
inhibited.
So the threat system is sort of always
on,
but as long as everything is happening
the way you expect it to happen,
then it's inhibited.
Now,
the way it's inhibited,
it seems to be at something like this,
there's a part of the brain that's very
deep called the reticular activating
system and the reticular activating
system is an ascending stream of of
neuronal connections,
and if you're in a car accident and
twist your head and you snap that
tracked because it's.
It's quite.
It's actually fairly fragile.
Then your unconscious forever and that's
that.
So it's very,
very important track and it seems to be
governing arousal.
What governs your emergence into
consciousness and your dissenting to
unconsciousness at night.
Very,
very,
very old brain system.
And it is.
What it seems to happen is that the
hippocampus detects a mismatch.
It,
it's tonically inhibiting the reticular
activating system,
so as long as everything is going
according to expectation,
the reticular activating system isn't
sending a message to the Amygdala and
other systems that are primarily
associated with emotion.
It's not sending a signal to them
saying,
wake the hell up,
but as soon as there's a mismatch,
then the hippocampus inhibition of the
reticular activating system declines and
the Amygdala and other emotional
systems,
motivational systems as well turn on,
so or are or are no longer inhibited,
which is a better way of thinking about
it.
Okay,
so now the.
So when gray,
who is also one of the cybernetic
theorists talks about what happens when
you hit something that's unexpected.
He basically says you have to revamp
your motor programs and your
expectations of the future in order to
reconcile the error and that that's a
complex process and it requires
exploration.
But the problem with that theory is
you don't have access to the present.
You have a model of the present and you
don't expect things to happen.
You want them to happen and so what that
means is if they don't happen the way
you want them to,
you have a bigger problem than the
cognitive cybernetic theorists
originally envisioned and the problem is
the place where the error might be is
way bigger.
It might be in what you want.
It might be in how you put together,
what you want with the other things you
want.
It might be how you put together all
those things with what other people
want.
It might be something wrong with your
conception of your abilities at the
present time.
It might be a skill deficit and it might
be something that's gone astray with
your conceptualization of the future,
how it's a big search space and so
that's part of the reason.
So you might say,
well,
what should you do when you hit
something you don't expect?
And the answer to that is you default to
emergency preparation.
Now how much do you default?
Well,
we don't quite understand the rat
representation yet because it's
associated with this hierarchical
problem we already described.
So I think it's got to be something like
this.
Your brain must be able to tell somehow
how much of it's structure is dependent
on a given on the viability of a given
node,
so so imagine that you have a
representation and hardly anything
depends on that representation and that
representation is disrupted.
It's like,
yeah,
that's no big deal because it's only
knocking out a part of what you're using
to orient yourself in the world.
But if it's a fundamental
presupposition,
maybe like the presence,
the continued presence,
a loved one on which all your other
plans are predicated because you can
imagine that sort of as a neural
structure,
if it's way down at the bottom and the
neural structure is branching off from
that and that gets disrupted.
It looks like that the hippocampal
septal system has some ability to sense
the degree to which a given
conceptualization is fundamental and the
maybe that has something to do with how
early in life it was laid down.
You know,
because you,
you know that once you make a
presupposition in childhood to Orient
Yourself than other,
more finely grained presuppositions are
going to emerge from that.
So maybe it has something to do with
depth of representation in the brain,
like,
or,
or the branching or the are account of
the branches that come off that I don't
know and I don't think anybody does,
but there has to be an association of
that sort.
Yep.
Well,
I can tell you one thing that's been
done about that.
So this is the kind of science that
people hate.
You may or may not know that I'm
Ashkenazi Jews.
European Jews on average have an Iq
that's about 15 points higher than the
rest of the Caucasian population.
And that's a lot.
And that's part of the reason why
they're massively overrepresented,
for example,
among,
well among people in most high level,
um,
occupations,
but among Nobel prize winners and so on,
they're also much more prone to neural
diseases that are associated with
hypergrowth.
So the fact that their brains are more
plastic in some sense,
comes along with susceptibility to a
variety of diseases of the nervous
system.
So that,
so there's an intelligence,
um,
proliferation problem there.
So your brain can be so plastic that it,
it starts to become abnormal.
So,
so we also know with regards to openness
per say,
that one of the,
here's one of the best tests for
openness.
We could do this right now.
I don't think we will,
but if I say,
okay,
take out a piece of paper and a pen and
write down as many words as you can that
begin with the letter s in three
minutes.
There's gonna be a lot of variation in
this group.
I would think it would be from 50 to
200.
Um,
the people who can write down more
words,
they're higher in openness,
they're more creative as well,
isn't it?
It's a pretty good predictor.
So that isn't so much,
I think an indication necessarily of the
complexity of the branches,
but it's certainly an indication how
rapidly you can access the information
that's in those branches.
So,
okay.
so that's how you maintained emotional
stability.
The way you intend emotional stability
is something like you have a conception
of how the world should lay itself out.
When you act as long as that conception
and your model of what's happening
match.
Then your hippocampus tells your
reticular activation,
reticular activating system to leave
your motivational and emotional systems
dormant,
and then if there's a mismatch,
it's like it's time to wake the hell up
in your paper when you're talking about
the map.
Hypothalamus,
we haven't talked about that yet,
but that's,
that's a perfectly reasonable question.
That's actually why I'm.
That was the most stable psychological
as well.
What was,
you mentioned that motivation is
motivation provides most stable of the
same logical strategy.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So,
so far so good.
Couldn't conceptualize the brain like
this.
You know,
you hear about emotions and motivations
and I'd say,
well those are low resolution boxes
because it actually turns out that if
you look at each of the major
motivational systems and you know,
you can argue about what they are,
but we can kind of lay them out.
Pain is one that's for sure.
That's an old one.
Thirst,
hunger,
sexual drive,
defensive aggression,
a predatory aggression,
a play.
I'm a love pair.
Bonding.
Um,
what else?
And then there's basic emotions,
you know,
those there's like hope and surprise
and,
and joy and fear.
And uh,
um,
discussed and that's good enough.
You get the picture,
you know,
when you can expand that and contract it
depending on how you conceptualize it.
And you can say,
well some of those are motivational
systems and some of them was her
emotional systems.
And the actual answer to that is,
well,
not exactly because that's only a low
resolution categorization system.
It might be useful to distinguish them
from cognitive systems,
but the truth of the matter is that each
of those systems has its own
neurological substrate and those
neurological substrates are not
identical.
Like there's some similarities between
them,
but there's lots of differences.
And so some things are more emotional
and some things are sort of half like
emotions and motivations.
Anger is sort of like that.
And then some things are more pure
motivations because hunger people don't
generally think of that as an emotion
and I think it has to do mostly with the
propensity of the underlying system to
establish an entire framework of
reference.
So hunger will do that.
Um,
anger will do that,
thirst will do that,
sexual drives will do that.
They come up,
they,
there's a associated with them,
it wants something,
it sees the world in that manner.
It,
it primes a certain class of behaviors
that are associated with that and it
runs like a partial personality,
but then something like fear seems to be
more something that exists and operates
within a framework rather than producing
its own framework.
So it doesn't matter.
The point is there's a lot of these
underlying systems and they have the
capacity to set up these frameworks of
reference that we're talking about and
to run the mass processes.
Yeah,
and the reason I said they're stable is
because they'll.
The deeper you'd go down into the brain,
the older the brain part is and the
hypothalamus,
it's really,
really old and it's so powerful that if
you take your whole brain off,
except for the hypothalamus and the
spinal cord,
which leaves you with no brain at all.
If you're a cat,
which is a pretty complicated thing and
you're female,
you can still pretty much exists.
So if you put a female cat in a box and
you take its brain off,
including even the emotional sectors and
you just leave it with the hypothalamus,
if you watch the cat can't handle novel
environments obviously because it can't
really learn.
But it can do cat things.
No problem.
It can feed itself,
it can engage in defensive aggression,
it can mate,
it can generally interact with its
kittens.
And one of the weird things is,
this is so funny,
a cat with no brain is hyper
exploratory.
It's like you think what the hell?
It's like you'd think it'd be the brand
that's doing the exploring.
It's like no,
it's the hypothalamus that's motivating
the exploring the brain stores the
results of the exploring and shuts the
exploration off.
So if you take the brain off then the
cat just runs around and trying to learn
things.
But it can't because it doesn't remember
anything.
So.
But it's quite fascinating because we
tend to think of the top part of the
brain is so bloody important.
It's like a no
is what
take the whole critical cap off and
almost all the emotional systems,
like 85 percent of the braid.
Nope.
Yes,
no motor cortex.
It's running on reflex.
If you're interested,
I actually have some diagrams of it,
but look up decorticate cat,
you know,
you can.
There's lots of.
Yeah,
well,
I mean,
you know,
other people did,
a lot of people have done a lot of
experiments on animals and their
neurological function and one of the
things they were interested in as well,
how much brain can you remove and still
have a functioning animal?
And the answer is pretty much all of it.
And that's like,
well,
who the hell would possible?
And if you're interested in that,
I would read Swanson again.
Uh,
and I'm sure that papers on the websites
that sorenson paper,
now that's a work of genius,
that thing.
Oh,
because they're male sexual behavior is
harder to organize.
And so decorticate males can mate.
So if you ever meet a male who can't
mate,
then anyways,
sorry.
But that's,
that's,
that's the reason is that there are
certain elements of,
of male sexual behavior that required
more complex organization.
So,
so that's one thing a decorticate male
can't do.
So it's easier to distinguish them from
females,
from the female cats.
That's,
that's the only reason.
So,
okay,
so you get the idea.
So like at the bottom of the brain,
there's all these systems that are
really alive and sort of on fire and
they're all generating up these
motivational frames of reference and,
and they,
they do that,
that's instinct,
so to speak,
you know,
and then all of that's elaborate it up
by the cortex and the Cortex is saying,
okay,
well these things are like a pack of
fighting two year olds.
So by the way,
and I mean that because if you take
children and you put them in age matched
groups and you.
So you have a group of 18 months olds
and two year olds and three year olds
and four year olds and so all the way up
to 16 year olds say and then you count
violent interactions,
kicking,
hitting,
biting,
stealing.
The two year olds are like,
they're just all over that,
but it's not actually quite right
because some of the two year olds are
peaceful and passive,
but there's a subset of the two year
olds that are like chaotic motivational
machines,
right?
They're just running around being as
impulsive as can possibly be,
and you can think about them as under
almost under complete hypothalamus
control.
You're just cycling from one intense
motivational state to another that makes
two year olds a blast.
Like they're really fun to be around
except they're kind of a pain in the
neck,
but they're really fun because they're
really on fire.
They're into this and into that,
into this,
and then they fall down because they're
too tired and then they wake up and
they're starving to death and you know
they're really alive.
But then what has to happen is that
those behaviors,
those motivational states,
which are sort of working in isolation,
they start to conflict with one another.
You know,
so that the child can't really organize
any medium to longterm behavioral
strategies being that impulsive.
So what the CORTEX is there is to start
sequencing those motivational systems in
higher order structures that allow each
of them to get what they need in order
to function across long periods of time
in increasingly complex social
environments.
That's what the CORTEX is for.
So it's a complex regulatory mechanism
and what it's doing is keeping.
It's like a nuclear reactor.
The core is really hot and fiery and you
need to sync rods into it to keep it
under control,
to dampen it.
Now it's really,
it's a good analogy for how your brain
works because the underlying systems
they're on,
they're on fire,
they're alive and the cortex is saying,
well,
a little bit of you now and a little bit
of you and then some of you and wait
your turn and so on,
and it sequences out over stretches of
time.
That's really socialization and that's
quite a different view than the Freudian
view of repression,
you know?
Because I would say you only have to
repress a motivational system if you're
not very successful.
Because if you're a successful and well
socialized person,
you don't have to suppress them or
repress them,
you just have to sequence them.
That's all because they're all going to
get what they want.
Right?
And that means that you're a good player
of complex social games and that has
very little to do with repression or
inhibition.
It's just sequencing.
It's important.
What time do we have?
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Good,
Oh,
so here's kind of an interesting way of
looking at the Amygdala.
This is from a Joseph Ledoux wrote a
lovely book on the Amygdala and it also
kind of shows you how your body is
structured.
And so,
you know,
I don't know if you've ever heard of the
phenomena of blind sight and do you know
what blind sight is?
Did I tell you about blind sight or did
you learn that somewhere else?
Okay.
Well,
anyways,
one way of being blind is to go like
this and then you can't see.
And another way is to have your retina
destroyed and maybe the optic nerve
could go another way of being blind.
Just have your visual cortex destroyed.
The thing about that's weird about
having your visual cortex destroyed is
that you think you can't see but you
still can.
You just can't see the same way you saw
before and you can't see objects
consciously.
But if someone says,
I've got one hand up,
which one is it?
And they say,
well,
I can't see it,
and you say,
guess.
Then they can guess,
and so you might say,
well how can that be?
And the answer to that is,
is that okay?
Imagine for a minute that the world
isn't made out of objects.
Imagine that it's made out of patterns
because it is made out of patterns.
Music is.
That's why music is so intensely
interesting because it's a
representation of the world as a place
of patterns and a pattern is something
that repeats because otherwise it
wouldn't be a pattern and the only thing
you really need to keep track of things
that repeat because there is no such.
There's no point knowing anything about
things that don't repeat because what
the hell good is your knowledge.
So the world is full of patterns.
What happens is that that pattern is
transformed into a pattern on your
retina.
It's a pattern of neuroactivation,
and then there's multiple branches from
your retina,
doesn't just go one place,
it goes lots of places and each of those
places it goes,
produces its own implementation of that
pattern,
and one of those implementations allows
you to see the world consciously,
but other implementations have other
functions.
So for example,
if you show someone with flying site and
angry face and you record their
psychophysiological responses and you
show them a neutral or a smiling face,
you can distinguish their physiological
responses to the angry or fearful face
from the happy or neutral face,
and the reason for that is that one of
the patterns that your retina is,
is picking up is the facial
configurations of human being
specifically because that's really
important to us and that's delivered to
a specific part of your brain.
It seems to be,
at least in part,
the Amygdala and what the Amygdala does
basically is says this.
I don't know.
That's not very good.
This means this,
so it maps that pattern onto this
pattern.
You don't need to see anything for that
to happen,
right?
You just have to translate the pattern
into motor action.
Lots of animals see that way.
So like when when a fly flies by a frog,
the frog doesn't see the fly and think,
well there's a fly and then like nails
it with its tongue.
It's like the fly flying by pattern
activates the tongue sticking out
pattern and it does it in like 100th of
a second as as a obviously because like
have you ever tried to catch a fly with
your tongue?
It's like it's not easy but a frog can
really do it.
And the fact that the frogs visual
system is so simple and specialized
means that there's hardly any neural
connections between the perception of
the pattern of the fly and the motor
response.
Like maybe there's two neurons
intermediate thing and so that frog and
nail that fly right now.
Whereas you,
you're going to wait around until you
see the fly and then you know you're
going to swat it and a fly sees this
loophole and it's like it's gone for.
It's gone in a week of flight time.
By the time you hit the,
by the time you hit the you know the
table with your flyswatter.
You don't want to rely on your conscious
vision to do extraordinarily fast things
because it takes under normal
conditions.
It takes maybe a quarter to half a
second to become consciously aware of a
phenomenal logical entity.
It's like for snakes or things like
that,
man,
they've bitten you by the time you see
them.
So what Luddu pointed out is that to the
underlying motivational areas,
there's lots of sensory inputs that
bypass the representational processing
that's characteristic of the cortex.
And so if you're walking down a path and
like a little snake like movement occurs
here,
you're going to catch that with the
periphery of your vision.
Now try this.
So look at this finger,
okay?
Now look at the finger,
but concentrate on my face.
Okay?
Don't look at my face.
You ready for that?
Okay.
Okay,
so what do you see?
What do you see?
Yeah,
you see the teeth and eyes and if like
look again,
if you,
if you pay careful attention,
you'll be able to see that you cannot
see my nose because who cares what my
nose is doing.
You don't care,
you're Mengele certainly doesn't care.
So why bother seeing it?
You're a make dilla cares about what the
hell you're eyes are pointing out and
whether or not your teeth are there and
it cares about that with other creatures
too.
And so your peripheral vision is low
resolution is wired up to detect
movement and threat and what does the
detection is super fast because well it
better be.
Are you going to get bit?
Okay.
So one day I was in California and I was
walking down this pathway on a cliff or
facing the ocean in La and it was,
I think it was march or something and
there was this guy in front of me,
this is like six foot seven and right in
front of him was his four year old
daughter.
So we're walking along and all of a
sudden she goes and jumps right onto his
shoulders.
It was like,
you know what cats,
like when you started just poof and runs
this,
a very funny thing to do to cats.
Um,
there was a rattlesnake right beside the
path.
Now it was kind of slow because it was
cold,
but obviously what had happened to her
is her periphery caught the rattlesnake
and she was up in her father's shoulders
before,
before she saw the snake.
And it's a good thing because if it was
a stick,
well who cares?
She's expanded a little energy,
you know,
so the Amygdala can be kind of low
resolution and it's still useful.
But if it,
if it was a snake and it was going to
strike the fact that she had jumped onto
his shoulders before she even saw it was
going to save her.
And so one of the things that in
principle,
the underlying motivational systems are
wired up to detect our primary fear
stimuli.
And so those would be.
You can kind of list them off now for a
long time.
People thought,
you learn to be afraid,
which I told you is a rubbish.
She learned not to be afraid.
Then they thought that you could learn
to be afraid to some things more easily
than others,
but you still had to be exposed to those
things and then they figured out,
no,
there's just things you're afraid of.
And one of those things is snakes and
chimpanzees for example,
they don't like snakes and even if you
raise chimps and monkeys,
so they never see a snake and you show
them a snake,
they are not happy about the snake.
So the snakes like Uber Predator,
you know,
I found now that mammals,
I should have known this,
been around for about 220 million years.
So we've been battling with reptiles for
a very long period of time right back
when there were dinosaurs anyways.
So the idea that like predatory reptiles
are a bad thing that's way deep down
inside of us.
And so we have systems that we've
conserved as we've evolved,
not because they're accurate but because
they're really damn fast.
And so one of the things your retinal
patterns do is map themselves right onto
your spinal cord.
And that's super fast,
super low resolution.
So it means your eyes can make your body
move.
There's almost no intermediation of
thinking.
And so the old behavioral ideas that you
were a stimulus response machine,
we're right,
except that you're a stimulus response
machine with a bunch of more complex
processes built on top of that.
But the stimulus response machine is
still there and the reason it's there is
because it's super fast.
And so there are these multiple levels
of the nervous system and as you go down
into more and more fundamental systems,
they're faster and more stereotyped.
And as you move up there are more
complex and slower and the sensory
systems have input more or less at each
level.
And so partly what your brain is trying
to figure out is when should you use the
quick and dirty systems and wind should
use the Slo and contemplate of systems.
And the answer is,
if it's a primary fear stimuli,
which would be fire teeth,
skeletons,
blood Genetalia,
generally speaking,
I'm Saudi it.
Oh,
uh,
immobile bodies.
Well,
and then there's all sorts of noises.
Baby cries.
For example,
we just did an experiment.
I told you guys about latent inhibition.
Do you remember that?
Maybe not.
If I,
uh,
if you listen to a bunch of numbers and
in the background you hear a white noise
burst,
sure.
So maybe I get you to listen to that for
three minutes and I tell you to count
your number.
Okay?
Then I play the same soundtrack and I
show you a bunch of lights and the
lights go on one by one.
And I tried to get you to predict what's
turning those lights on.
If I may get the white noise burst,
and you've already heard that for three
minutes when it didn't signify anything,
it's going to be very difficult for you
to learn that the white noise bursts are
now what turns on the lights.
So the way you determine that as you
play people before exposing them to the
lights,
one tape that has the white noise bursts
and another tape that doesn't.
And then you play both of them,
both groups,
the white noise burst and the numbers
and turn on the lights,
and the people who weren't pre-exposure
to the white noise learn it faster by a
substantial amount that's called latent
inhibition.
And that's what makes things invisible
for you.
You see things,
nothing happens.
You learned to ignore them,
they're irrelevant.
So you're using latent inhibition to
eradicate their relevance.
We did it with baby cries.
People don't develop latent inhibition
to baby cry.
So if you put a little baby crying in
the back instead of white noise,
it doesn't matter how many times do you
expose the person to it,
they,
they learned that the baby cried turns
on the lights right away.
And so what I'm thinking is that the way
that your brain makes things relevant is
it makes everything irrelevant except
for certain categories of things that
you can't learn to habituate to no
matter what you do.
And those would be the categories I just
described.
You know,
and the fact that Janet Halley are part
of that,
especially for men,
if it's pictorial representations,
accounts for the absolutely addictive
nature of pornography,
so you can't,
you cannot habituate to the images,
although men do to some degree,
but it's very difficult habituate to
those images.
So,
okay,
so your brain assumes that everything is
relevant and important until you learn
that it isn't.
And once you learn it,
it isn't.
You don't even pay any attention to it.
And then your brain basically removes
the blocking from things
dependent on your state of motivation.
That's what makes it relevant.
So for example,
if you get hungry,
if you're not hungry,
foods irrelevant if you are hungry than
the latent inhibition gets stripped off
the food.
And so all of a sudden it's all
meaningful and interesting.
Again,
just like it was before you're,
before you learned that it was
irrelevant.
Um,
here's the list of Amygdala output.
Same idea basically apply.
So the sensory systems put input into
multiple levels of the nervous system,
but the emotional systems and the
motivational systems also have multiple
levels of output to the brain hierarchy.
So I'm Ledoux is identified,
this is partly associated with anxiety,
Tachycardia,
increased heart rate,
galvanic skin response,
Paleness,
pupil dilation,
blood pressure,
elevation ulcers.
This is more chronic urination,
defecation,
again,
Bradycardia,
panting,
respiratory distress,
behavioral and Eeg arousal,
increased vigilance,
increased attention,
heightened startle,
freezing hyperalgesia,
so you can't feel pain as much.
Facial expressions of fear and
corticosteroid release.
So you see that when you say,
well,
what's fear?
It's like,
well,
it's a multilevel phenomena and it
manifests itself across different
hierarchies of the nervous system and so
and,
and those systems different complexity.
And they did and they differ in speed,
you know?
And the other thing for humans,
what's happening if you encounter
something anxiety producing is it sends
a signal up to the right hemisphere and
it says,
provide a quick and dirty model of this.
And then it tells the left hemisphere
and if you can explore a bunch together,
new information so that we can improve
the model.
And so that's basically how you're
responding to novelty.
Now the next thing I'm going to tell you
not today is two things.
One is how these hierarchical systems
emerge across time.
And how they're interrelated,
but then,
and this is where we can really move in
another direction quickly,
I want to show you how these domains,
because we've outlined some domains,
the domains are
things that turn out the way you want
them to,
things that don't turn out the way you
want them to.
Structures of representation and modes
of updating that structure of
representation.
So you can think about those as their
constants.
Some things you can predict,
understand some things you can't,
that you can explore.
You can be conventional and there is a
characteristic nature of the domain that
consists of things that you do not
expect or desire.
So the next hypothesis is those are the
things that are represented in mythology
and the reason they're represented is
because there are constants.
They're always there.
And so what mythology does it isn't
doing this.
This is just what happened is it lays
out these domains,
it attributes to them certain.
And then it says on average,
here's how you should conceptualize them
and deal with them.
And that's what stories are.
So what I'll do next is I'll show you
the symbolic realms.
And then we can walk through how those
are manifested in stories and you'll see
that the stories all of a sudden become
alive and that's really cool because the
stories are really useful and not only
are they useful,
they're accurate,
they actually tell you what to do.
So and things chaos in order.
Okay.
That was to have them.
Order is where things that you want to
happens and chaos is where things you
don't want to happen.
And then the next thing,
broadly speaking,
is the thing that mediates between those
and that would be your consciousness.
And then there's a fourth category which
is a really weird category and it's the
category from which all those things
emerge.
So that's a really rough one to get your
head around.
But it sort of something like this.
There's unknown things that you can more
or less conceptualize and categorized
because they're not completely outside
of your experience.
And then there's the unknown as such.
It's sort of like raw potential and that
potential,
the mythology conceptualized is that
potential as the fundamental bedrock of
being.
And it assumes that all those other
phenomenon emerge out of it,
so you emerge out of potential.
That's a perfectly reasonable way of,
of thinking about the mythological
representation.
So we're going to lay those out in
detail.
I'm going to tell you a bunch of stories
using those categories and walk you
through it.
I'm going to tell you how those
mythological categories are constituted
and what they mean.
And then we're going to figure out how
they need to relate to one another.
And so good stories tell you how they
relate to one another.
That's what makes them good.
So,
and you know that because otherwise you
wouldn't know the difference between a
good story in a bad story.
So that's what's coming up.
And so hopefully I won't have to go over
what we went over today again,
but I really need you to get this first
part clear because otherwise when we go
to the next stage,
it will make any sense at all.
So okay,
go ahead.